він просто кричав щоб хтось його добив
Він казав що він тоді був просто в
розпачі що він не знав вже він не вірив
те що він виживе до мене взагалі ніколи
не було в думках що я можу когось добити
очі боялись руки робили Я просто
діставав турнікети все йому накладався
як треба було робити і не слухав його не
Я слухав тільки як кулі літають як
міномета літають щоб тільки не в мене
Потім зі мною зв'язались хлопці там
натівці бійці і вони використовують для
навчання бісів НАТО це відео бо там є
моменти як я зробив правильно як я
зробив неправильно на війні все просто
опускається до
того момента що тобі треба вижити і Ну
там все це якось забувається І вже через
рік півторити навіть не пам'ятаєш ким ти
був до війни всі команди два допомогу
вони вижили і всі знали що якщо когось
поранить він не обов'язково виживе бо я
його звідти витягну це найгірша війна
Яка ставалась в історії людства що ну
навіть Друга світова війна попри всі ті
мільйонні втрати вона поряд не стоїть з
шахами цієї війни
звати Мене конопля Петро Володимирович я
боєць 35-ї бригади морської піхоти
бойовий медик саме виконував обов'язки
бойового медика до війни працював
актором намагався бути режисером ставив
свою першу рицарську роботу якої так і
не сталося
того повномасштабного вторгнення я жив
дуже прекрасне життя і я мріяв поставити
свою виставу мені залишалось там два
тижні аби є її вже здав
І починається війна Я живу прямо біля
порту в мене домакицька і
починають обстрілювати ППО десь зі
сторони Порту починає обстрілювати небо
Я взагалі не служив в армії ніколи е-е я
ніколи не тримав в руках зброї Я ніколи
не бачив як навіть працює зброя як воно
стріляє і коли у мене така Панорама
прямо на море і
починається просто якісь Зіркові війни
по всьому небу в мене кицька бігає по
всій квартирі я намагаюся її спіймати
щоб втікти звідти бо думаю що Ну от
зараз прилетить просто випадково якийсь
уламок якась куля є бігав по квартирі
ловив кицьку е-е піймав кицьку засунув
її в куртку і їхав звідти її якнайдалі
дуже було страшно Я дуже перелякався
коли зрозумів що почалась війна отак і
Ну перше що мені впало на це треба
швидко від'їжджати з усіма своїми
родичами просто тікати і ну якнайдалі і
був просто момент коли я проїжджав по з
блокпосту на якому стояли хлопці які
мали би зустрічати перших ворогів на
під'їзді до нашого міста і я тоді
побачив що там стоять 23-24 рочки хлопці
геть молоді Ну ще у деяких щетина на
обличчі не з'явилася і я тоді думаю Ну
оце так що зараз пів міста біжить пів
міста пішло до війська а ці хлопчики
стоять на сохраняють і я зараз буду або
втечу і вони ще вони зараз сюди зайдуть
або ну
не піду у військо буду чекати поки вони
мене захистять я так і не поїхав е-е я
вирішив ще не можу поїхати Що Ну от як я
тут все зараз залишу
Моя мама зараз за кордоном Моя сестра
зараз за кордоном
я залишився тут пішов до військкомату
кажу
беріть мене військо Я готовий вони
кажуть в нас тут черга
із бажаючих Якщо хочеш ми тебе запишемо
в список вони записали мене в список і
Ну мені було дуже важко знаходитись
вдома я не розумів що ми далі робити Ти
дивишся ці новини і ти розумієш що Ну
все капець просто що зараз в нас всіх
е-е знищить і я побачив проблему у мене
було дуже багато знайомих які все ж
пішли прямо в ту саму ніч і вони вже
служили воювали їх вже приписали десь до
яких частин і виявили що у нас в місті
не облаштована ніяка оборона міста ніхто
цього не робить не вистачає людей і коли
мені позвонили знайомі з Херсона і
сказали що там Херсон вже взяли і взяли
його буквально там за лічені години
хвилини то я зрозумів що Одесу так само
Зараз прийдуть і візьмуть і ми з
хлопцями зібралися компанією мислили
свої
майбутні дії створилася група в
телеграмі де зібралася там за пару годин
зібралися з півтори тисячі бажаючих
отако ми їх знайомих їх знайомих які
були готові грузити пісок в мішки возити
все це укріпляти блокпости рити
протитанкові траншеї
будувати бліндажі
для військових будувати КПП е-е
вварити протитанковій їжі все це возити
мене впізнавали тоді по місту я їздив на
мопеді в мене на спині був український
флаг
стяг такий і називали мене капітаном
Україною і я там їздив постійно мене на
кожному блокпості знали і наступає 13
березня Я з хлопцями ми будуємо ще
якийсь там бліндаж На в'їзді з Миколаєва
в Одесу і мені телефонують кажуть тут є
місце в терео Одеському приїжджайте
військкомат вони мене забрали в рот
охорони міста і я був В роті охороніша
перших два місяці
ну був набором морську піхоту прийшов
запрос на 40 людей і я записався прямо
кажу я хочу йти їм морська піхота це ж
Одеська бригада наша бригада І мені
хотілося піти в морську піхоту Мій
батько
Він дуже хотів там моряком його вони в
море і я думав ну якби він був би живий
він би мене підтримував щоб я пішов
морську піхота це еліта армії і Я вважав
що якщо в мене візьмуть морську піхоту
то це вже прямо
дуже круто
і пішов до морської піхоти дуже багато
навчався і в роті охорони навчався і на
цивільних курсах навчався і в морській
піхоті мене навчали і
побратими навчали ми всі один на одному
бобиві медицині саме тактичній медицині
І от З 1
серпня у нас почалась Берка почалась
бойові дії коли я дізнався що таке фронт
що таке війна що таке страх
Це був Херсон і
Це була каструмки це перше було село яке
ми брали
ой дуже це знаєте як кажуть перший бій
Він самий страшний то був дуже страшний
бій і є як ми туди потрапили як це
відбувалося І Ну все було як в кіно
такого ніколи не забудеш Я вважаю що це
моя перша день народження було то 1
вересня
Слава Богу Я тоді отримав тільки
контузію
ну хвилин через 10 після початку бою я
вже стрімголов біг в другий край посадки
де мені сказали що у нас там
2-31 200 і ми з напарником вже туди
бігли бігли до свого першого пораненого
який лежав під деревом дуже блідий у
нього осколком розпарололо бік живота і
він там лежав і ножем копав собі окоп Я
бачив кіно я чув розповіді Ну щоб
ну мені здавалося що ми потрапили просто
в саме пекло коли ти бачиш що гелікоптер
злітає з їхньої сторони злітає глікоптер
накидує отако і сідає потім виїжджає На
поле танки починає нас обстрілювати
міномети постійно обстрілюють касети в
тебе летять кулеметом в тебе стріляють
ну взагалі все це 7 годин і це було
просто щось
неймовірне бо важко було повірити що
можна задіяти таку кількість техніки
людей І
мені здавалося що ми звідти більше не
виберемось нікого Ну якийсь такий стан
був але коли в нас стало все виходити
Коли ми
з'ясували що в нас ситуація
більш-менш контрольована
навіть попри весь оцей хаос який ти
бачиш вперше
постало якось трохи легше і ми звідти
вибрались з мінімальними втратами Ну ми
мені так здавалось що на ту кількість
снарядів які вони на нас витратили За
весь цей час у нас мало бути набагато
більше втрат ніж їх було
я в той день повірив в Бога
11-го взяла Херсон 13-го ми вже були на
Донецькому напрямку більше ніж півроку я
провів на мар'їнці
Мар'їнка це таке Ну це місто там бойові
дії відбуваються прямо в місті і там
ховатися можна тільки в підвалі будинку
якогось І зовсім відрізняється самі
бойові дії
Херсон і посадки Мар'їнка і міста
там потрібно дуже добре знати дорогу я
був дуже багато разів провідником який
вводив хлопців туди і назад там треба
дуже швидко рухатись там
якщо ти завернеш не за той Google тебе
можуть взяти в полон і дуже важко Дуже
важко діставати побратимів просто танк
може вдарити завалити людину і ви її не
розкопаєте бо там уже прям техніка треба
щоб її розказати
бойовий медик - це повноцінно бойова
одиниця і він ти і стріляєш ти і там
допомогу надаєш але але ну є все ж таки
свої але тебе використовують тільки в
крайньому випадку Якщо хтось окрім тебе
може вести бій то він веде бій
всі побратими повинні тебе берегти бо
якщо тебе не буде
ну от це
[музика]
не буде кому доглядати за пораненим не
буде кому витягати
люди бережуть мене тому що в них є
більша впевненість що вони виберуться
звідси живими Ну в мене є така моя
невеличка медалька Що Ніхто з моїх
поранених ще не помирав всі команди два
допомогу вони вижили і всі знали що якщо
когось поранить він не обов'язково
виживе бо я його звідти витягнув я в
загалом Не розкриваю цю тему про свою
участь в ближніх боях але саме мій
великий страх стався в ближньому бою це
коли я надавав допомогу хлопцю коли я
його перев'язував і намагався врятувати
А на мене з кущів вивезло чотири
ворога чотири орка
і мені довелося використати зброю
причому Я зовсім не очікував їх і в мене
було два поранених один біля одного Я
коли прибіг я лишив свою сумку медичну
біля першого пораненого і свій автомат
там теж лишив і тут сталось так що от
вони просто вискочили зненацька на мене
і біля мене лежав кулемет ПКМ кулемет
Калашнікова
і я схопив того кулемета просто від
страху все що
все що всередині в мене було що в нас
зараз всіх просто вб'ють і їх і мене і
Ну я просто постриг там все ж можна було
постригти тим кулеметом Буквально за
хвилину напевно сестрічку випустив
це відео
сталося 20 квітня коли ми вже нас уже
зняли з бойового розпорядження Ми
виїхали з марінки і мали би відпочивати
якимось найближчим часом але ми вже
сиділи три дні на сумках зібрали всі
свої речі мали вже кудись переїжджати
мали на навчання якісь поїхати і на
передислокацію перегрупування на
доокомплектацію ну якось все це так
називалось і тут нам кажуть що зараз
на
у-у такому участку фронту біля бахмуту
стався прорив ворога і там ну нема кому
закрити той прорив і
зараз з нашого підрозділу збирають групу
аби кинути і туди щоб закрити цей прорив
і ну група зібралася
там майже всі їхали добровільно
але з групою постійно повинен їхати
медик а тоді єдиний медик був це я і так
я кажу я поїду їде група я поїду поїхала
Ну ми приїхали туди Це був дуже важкий
напрямок по-перше ми не знали тієї
місцевості ми тільки приїхали з іншої
місцевості дуже складна була обстановка
бо там дійсно був дуже міцний такий
прорив ворог великої кількості там
наступив і
вбили дуже багато наших попередників які
там були до того і
я тоді просто бачу всю цю історію Так що
це майже не останній бій в який от я
прийшов от я прямо для себе вирішив що
якщо я тут і помру то
Я зроблю все від себе можливе
і в принципі
ми тримали оборону так як мали тримати
ми йшли на зачистку посадки ми потрапили
в засідку ми від цієї засідки відбилися
Ми отримали перевагу і перемогу в цій
засідці ми відступили до своїх
окотів але нас щільно накривали артою і
мені параді які передали про поранених я
побігти поранених та перев'язувати
віднослювати не евакуацію Після того як
я вже відніс поранених Я вже повертався
назад і почув що нас обходять що там мої
хлопці ведуть бій вони В окопах почувши
в нашому ходять і а там наш Дрон літає і
так як він пояснив що нас обходять якраз
з тої сторони де прямо я зараз
знаходжусь і в мене був напарник якого я
призначив напарником
Ми вирішили що ми прямо тут станемо і
будемо чекати поки вони сюди підуть на
обхід якщо підуть то ми їх тут е-е
які інчому або хоча б дамо знак хлопцям
де знаходиться ворог і куди треба вести
Вогонь
і ми чекали на ворога
Ми вирішили що ми почекаємо
ворога І от ми сіли тут засідку я
поповнював собі патрони і під час того
як ми чекаємо я поповнюю патрони я чую
що хтось кричить і саме ці два хлопці
вони кричали вона накривали атою І там
вони недалеко в принципі від мене лежали
метрів 30 я залишу напарника на тому
місці де він і де ми чекали ворога а сам
побіг на допомогу
пораненим
і я чую що вони кричать і перше що я
кричу їм куди там ну це там відео
починається з того що я кричу куди мені
важливо було зрозуміти де поранення у
людини і коли я зрозумів що не можу мені
відповісти і я бачу що в нього влучання
прямо в лице у нього уламком відірвало
кусок щелепи і поряд з ним в 5 м лежало
ще два хлопці один був дуже сильно
поранений в нього були порвані обидві
руки обидві ноги в нього залетіло йому в
тулоп декілька уламків пробило одну
легеню
порізало біля тазової кості
і відключити доби мене Ну він там вже
Лежав і він бачив в якому він стані він
Ну ми вже потім не поговорили він каже
слухай я розумів що мене звідси ніхто
вже не витягне А що евакуація далеко що
ніхто мені не надасть більше допомогу я
каже тільки не хотів
мучитись і повільно Помирати тому я
просив щоб вони Хтось добив уже е-е
там всі хлопці навколо контужені до
найближчих далеко і він просто кричав
щоб хтось його добив Він казав що він
тоді був просто в розпачі що він не знав
вже він не вірив те що він виживе
до мене взагалі ніколи не було в думках
що я можу когось добити що Отак буде
лежати людина і просити його добити
візьмуть добью я тоді в якийсь навіть
момент я тоді думав що він буде
інвалідом до кінця життя
але
[музика]
очі боялись руки робили Я просто
діставав турнікети все йому накладав все
мотався як треба було робити і не слухав
його не Я слухав тільки як кулі літають
як міномети літають щоб тільки не в мене
[музика]
один з турнікетів ну на той день Це вже
був третій турнікет бо я до того ще в
мене були хлопці які не надавав допомогу
браковині китайські турнікети це дуже
велика проблема взагалі в армії в моєму
підрозділі зараз є старший бойовий там
медик наді мною який зібрав вже колекцію
турнікетів які не мають бути на війні і
як Я закликаю перевіряти всіх хто
передає ці турнікети військовим
волонтери чи
лікарі щоб вони перевіряли ці турнікети
на
якість бо я би саджав за таке В той
самий момент коли цей турнікет має бути
використаним Він
ну його дуже довго використовують і це
не не рятує життя бійців коли я той
турнікет маю три рази закрутити щоб він
вже щільно закрутився ми нарахували по
відео я 19 разів його закрутив і в
кінці-кінців він лопнув на нього потім
такий самий тонікар дістався мені коли
вже я отримав поранення і я теж його
намагався на собі закрутити і він на
мене лопнув Це добре що в мене було
масивної кровотечі
дуже велика проблема була дістати того
хлопця звідти бо
щоб одну людину нести треба 4 людини щоб
несли ночі а нас тоді Було
нащадро було з пораненим пораненим не
міг його нести і ми чекали четверту
людину і це теж дуже велика проблема в
війську це нормальні ноші бо в нас були
м'які ночі які дуже легко переносити які
в мене Ну в мене там було їх штуки Три
відразу На моїй там медичній сумці вони
маленькі компактні їх переносити зручно
але незручно не користуватись і вже
після цього відео от нам передали такі
пластикові ночі Вони складаються Але ти
можеш одну людину на них погрузити і
можеш сам її звідти витягти Тобто ти її
прямо тягнеш за собою вона сколізить по
траві по болоту по мокрому по снігу самі
круті ночі які я взагалі бачив
всі хлопці вижили
якраз під час того як я надавав допомогу
цьому хлопцю на нас і
вийшли ті чотири невдахи
або я щасливчик або вони невдахи Бо я їх
з цих побачити
і ну напевне Це був один із моїх
найжахливіших виходів бо поранених за
весь час в мене було дуже багато але
конкретно такої таких обставин В мене ще
не було на війні Коли б я так от під
кулями під тиском і вже коли ми виносили
його цього пораненого важкого то
прилетіли мені пробило мені наскрізь
ногу залишилось найгірше 5 уламків і
Ну я проходив весь цей час більш трьох
місяців проходив лікування
зараз я пройшов в ВК на придатність і
мене признали непридатним до служби в
морській піхоті бо морська піхота - це
високомобільнні війська і там з деякими
проблемами служити не можна тому зараз я
маю на меті працювати інструктором
готувати нових бойових медиків які б
могли б замінити мене які б могли б е-е
працювати і рятувати далі хлопців
[музика]
Я з усіма хлопцями як з якими мені
доводилось працювати я з усіма на
зв'язку з деякими я прямо до них
приїжджаю як до цього я приїжджав до
нього прямо в лікарню оглядав його ну і
зараз я йому продовжую допомагати інший
не скоро повернеться йому ще дуже довго
лікування пересадка шкіри пересадка
м'язів
імпланти реабілітація щоб він ходити
взагалі міг я показувати відео лікарям
які вже працювали зі мною з пораненим
там хірургами я показую кажуть Ну слухай
руку йому точно відріжуть ногу тоже Ну
скоріше за все відріжуть Ну а інше якщо
пощастить то йому ще пошиють і
я вже виклав те відео бо кажу Ну я не
можу знайти це хлопців якщо хтось
можливо знає якусь інформацію то скажіть
мені будь ласка
і те відео дуже швидко розлетілося
інтернетом його почали шарити з ним
почали створювати тіктоки з ним почали і
його почали викладати в себе і
вороги на Telegram каналах Десь навіть
не його їхньому телебаченні щось там
пролетіло і на нашому телебаченні через
якийсь певний час
все ж таки зі мною зв'язався його брат
бо він нічого не написати не міг вже
потім знайшли ту групу в телеграмі вона
називається бойова конопля це там ну
група де я показую все що я роблю на
фронті про моїх побратимів на фронті де
ми збираємо на тепловізори на маліке на
ну на різні прилади для моїх хлопців і
ми з ним Так поспілкувались він каже
слухай мене все пошили руки цілі ноги
цілі все ну все пошили що там мали б
відрізати точно ногу і точно руку А в
нього все ціле і
все буде працювати І він не буде
інвалідом І це мене прямо ну для мене це
було прям щось
спочатку мені почали там писати в
коментарях
американці вони не все розуміли що там
говорять на тому відео потім хтось з них
взяв і виклав це відео на американський
стрімінгові сервіс ребіт і перевів його
дослівно Потім зі мною зв'язались хлопці
там натівці бійці кажуть А можна ми
будемо використовувати ваше відео для
навчання і я кажу Ну як я можу
заборонити воно вже в інтернеті Ну типу
ми хочемо щоб ви написали прямо письмово
Так я даю згоду
для них це було важливо і вони
використовуються відео ну тобто вони
моделюють конкретну ситуацію от як вся
що там треба накласти так багато
турнікетів і вони надягають навіть
навушники на бійця щоб той чув всі ці
постріли міномети щоб він реагував на
все це і вони використовують для
навчання бісів НАТО це відео бо там є
моменти як я зробив правильно як я
зробив неправильно
і ці відео побачила спільнота бойових
медиків України і вони почали один між
одним його розкидувати якось і мені дуже
багато водночас написало різних медиків
що вони по цьому відео Ну це як мануал
Вони почали там навчати своїх людей
показувати своїм бійцям і це стало прямо
ну таким навчальним посібником
мрію щоб закінчилась ця війна і я міг
повернутись до своєї роботи бо Ну щось я
там не закінчив і мені дуже хочеться
закінчити довести що в мене є все ж таки
здібності 2020 році я знявся в
військовому фільмі він називається
світло фільм про військового який є
помирає ну це все що я поки можу сказати
але фільм
там якось так сталося що він не зміг
вийти в 20-му році по-перше нам них не
не вистачило фінансування для того щоб
його домонтувати а потім один карантин
другий карантин а потім війна і Він
вийшов тільки в началі на початку цього
року вже під час війни але за весь той
час що він монтувався змінилися
обставини сприйняття того фільму і зараз
цей фільм їздить поки на фестивалі і Ну
от мені нещодавно передали що він став
номінантом на золоту дзигу це ну на
найвища винагорода в українському кіно
Загалом я думаю що в мене пошкодились
трохи пам'ять після всіх цих контузів бо
в мене Ну так щоб порахувати щоб
конкретно знати то Їх було три А так щоб
не рахувати То напевно трошки більше
зафіксованих тільки одна Я зрозумів що я
дуже погано розмовляю Ну в мене є якісь
я в дитинстві заїкався і шепелявив і в
мене почало Це трошки повертатися я
Почав забувати деякі слова в мене
погіршилась пам'ять і ну це трошки мені
шкодить бо якийсь час в мене голова
навіть не на своєму місці була Важко
було розмовляти
пищало все в вухах е-е
акторська робота це коли ти постійно
читаєш постійно вчишся постійно
знаходишся серед людей І спілкуєшся на
різні теми Ти постійно в цьому
розвиваєшся А на війні все просто
опускається до
того момента що тобі треба вижити і Ну
там
все це якось забувається І вже через рік
півторити навіть не пам'ятаєш ким ти був
до війни наче все це було в якомусь Ні
наче все це було не з тобою не насправді
це найгірша війна Яка ставалась в
історії людства що навіть Друга світова
війна попри всі ті мільйонні втрати вона
поряд не стоїть з шахами цієї війни
люди які воювали десь в Африці в
Афганістані
в АТО то вони казали що Ну от ми ніколи
такого не бачили або у підрозділі були
ті хлопці які пройшли дві чи три війни і
ця війна на жахливіша яка була в їхньому
чи нашому взагалі житті
і Ну в мене якось Був знайомий він каже
типу Петро а заради чого ти підеш
воювати а що тобі твоя країна дала а
вона тобі дала квартиру а вона тобі дала
роботу А вона що тобі дала твоя країна
що Україна має Земної бігати щось мені
має давати Я сам піду і сам візьму все
що мені належить і я тоді зрозумів що
зараз моя країна хочеш щоб я її захистив
що зараз
от вона в такому важливому моменті коли
я маю вибрати її майбутнє і що країна
мені ще нічого не винна тільки тому що я
тут народився коли її захищу коли я
побудую ту країну яку я хочу побудувати
і бачити тоді я вже буду казати що от Я
все зробив а країна мені нічого не дала
а я пішов і взяв все що хотів І зараз я
вважаю що справжні сини України які
пішли її захищати вони йдуть і беруть
вони не чекають поки їм хтось щось
вдасться
[музика]